so there's no money for poor Americans
and the people that I see are living
because of the inflation and because of
what's happening at this with this
desperation the average wage in this
country is now $5,000 left less than the
cost of um of basic goods and you have
all these Americans now who are living
hand to mouth and uh and they do not
feel that anybody is listening to them
in the political process they feel
they've been compl completely abandoned
by the Democratic party and the
Republican Party particularly now you
know the Democratic party has had this
very interesting shift where when I grew
up the Democratic party was where the
people who were
poor and working people were and
today 70% of the wealth in this country
is owned by the Democratic party and
only 30% the Republican Party the top 10
count counties the top richest counties
in this country nine of the 10 are
democratic C counties